where is Moth Gideon at is he locked up
right now yeah he's in a precarious
position isn't he last we saw him he was
struggling to figure out who was Behind
the Green Door you know besides uh baby
grogu uh moff is gonna you know look
he's a guy who is Wily he's a thinker
he's ahead of people he knows everything
and he's going to figure it out quickly
and in the moment so you just wait and
see we had that moment at the end of the
season where he almost killed himself
versus getting captured which makes me
think he has a greater leader that he's
working for oh well I couldn't say that
I mean I am uh well I always think of
myself personally as the Grand Puba I
don't want to answer to anyone
um I don't know if moth answers to
anyone I can't say that I know that that
could be but it's a possibility one of
the first things he says is you have
something I want and one of the last
things he says is I have what I want
which is grogu's blood
I cannot tell if that is a bluff or not
but does what what is his goal now you
have something I want well I mean look
at the language that you already
described I mean his goal is to do
something extraordinary and I think um
that's for me to know and you to find
out
we've had so many we've had the child
Boba Fett still lives Luke Skywalker how
do you guys even top that in season
three what can you tease about what we
can expect in terms of surprise oh you
just wait and see I mean you know Dave
filoni and John Favreau in this
collaboration are
um they are ultimately really big brain
and they're big big kids who are able to
give you something that you never
imagined so I don't think there's any
way to figure it out before you see it
because their imagination is so big and
so huge uh and playful as well uh that
it's going to top everything of
everything you've seen and all that you
thought now people are getting really
tired of me calling Pedro daddy so I
have decided that I will now bestow that
honor over to you and you are now my
daddy oh my goodness so who's your Daddy
I am awesome congratulations wear it
with pride I will thank you very much
thank you so good to see you
[Music]
thank you